et depuis cette invasion russe les
sanctions a déployés par les pays
occidentaux contre la russie se
multiplient les occidentaux ont voulu
frapper un grand coup plusieurs banques
russes vont être exclu de la plateforme
des changes swift et ce matin le rouble
russe chute de près de 30% suite à ces
sanctions on retrouve tout de suite
notre envoyé spécial à moscou julie
d'une belle offre bonjour julie comment
les russes réagissent à ces sanctions
parlé avec de nombreuses personnes et
hier à moscou et pour tout vous dire il
y en a beaucoup qui n'était pas au
courant de ces sanctions et qui ne
comprenait pas vraiment les conséquences
qu'elles pouvaient avoir quand on
tentait d'en discuter avec eux il faut
dire qu'ici il y a beaucoup de
désinformation l'information est
extrêmement filtré quant on regarde les
médias russes et est bien seul le
narratif du du kremlin filtre sur sur
ces médias et il faut aller sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant des vpn
pour obtenir les informations c'est ce
que mon 10 de nombreuses personnes avec
lesquelles j'ai pu parler notamment des
jeunes qui sont habitués à utiliser ces
réseaux il ya beaucoup quand même
d'inquiétude dans la population russe et
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
il ya vraiment un fossé qui se creuse
entre ancien et un nouvelle génération
l'ancienne génération qui a et bien vécu
sous l'urss soutient davantage cette
guerre alors que la jeune génération
n'en comprend pas l'intérêt et ce même
s'il ne soutiennent pas l'ukraine il
s'agit simplement de se dire pourquoi au
21ème siècle en 2022 et bien la russie
s'engage dans une guerre beaucoup de
craintes d'un éventuel retour en arrière
notamment de se voir un déclassement du
pays une jeune femme me disait hier
qu'elles craignaient et bien que la
russie soit isolés du monde et l'imploré
presque 1 me disait s'il vous plaît
faites la différence entre nous peuples
russe et nos gouvernants nous n'y sommes
pour rien dans cette guerre donc une
inquiétude qui monte dans la population
et qui montent également sur un autre
sujet c'est sort des soldats russes un
beaucoup craignent de voir des soldats
revenir dans des cercueils et ça c'est
une donnée qui pourrait faire pencher
l'opinion publique est embêté
a dit mir écoute il la russie qui
communiquent pour la première fois sur
le fait qu'il ya des morts et des
blessés au combat en ukraine sans pour
autant et bien en communiquer le nombre
julie des voix en russie commence tout
de même à s'élever un contre cette
guerre en ukraine
oui hier j'ai pu me rendre dans le
centre de moscou à différents endroits
de la ville il y avait plusieurs
manifestations plus que des
manifestations ce sont des petits
rassemblements car les manifestations
sont interdites et des manifestations
ont eu lieu dans 40 villes du pays 290
personnes auraient été arrêtées lors de
ces manifestations et notamment des
journalistes les slogans sont toujours
les mêmes non à la guerre et puis
d'autres personnes tente timidement de
s'opposer à cette guerre tentes ils ont
peur et bien de se faire arrêter ils
viennent notamment déposer des fleurs
devant l'ambassade d'ukraine pour
apporter leur soutien à l'ukraine et ce
qui est intéressant à observer c'est
aussi des personnalités russes qui
commence à s'opposer à cette guerre on a
vu il y a quelques jours notamment une
célèbre danseuse du bolchoï le ballet
russe s'opposait à cette guerre on a vu
une tribune de 300 journalistes prenant
le risque de s'exprimer contre cette
guerre d'ailleurs la personne qui était
à l'initiative de cette tribune s'est vu
retirer son accréditation
on a vu également une tribune de
chercheurs qui s'opposaient à cette
guerre et hier ce qui a été intéressant
à observer c'est notamment et bien ce
qu'on peut appeler une défection d'un
diplomate à l'onu un diplomate russe qui
s'est excusé au nom du peuple russe de
ne pas avoir réussi à s'opposer à cette
guerre est un célèbre
oligarques russes milliardaires russes
qui a également publié une lettre
ouverte pour dire que cette guerre
serait une tragédie non seulement pour
l'ukraine mais aussi pour la russie
merci julie pour toutes ces précisions
vous étiez en direct de moscou au foie